I'd like to consider with you two
different groups of people and what the
information we know about them tells us
about those groups of people's so here's
my first group of people eyes up have a
look at these numbers with me right I
want you to imagine a hypothetical group
of 28 students okay and in that
hypothetical group of 28 students 21 of
them have black hair six of them have
brown hair and it just so happened that
exactly one of them has red hair okay
now if you were to represent this
hypothetical group of students in a Venn
diagram what would the Venn diagram look
like hmm what do you think hearing I'm
gonna have some mutually exclusive
circles we've already established these
because it don't overlap how many um how
many circles am I gonna need how many
hair colors do I have I have I have
three of them right so if you wanted I
could say just one on the outside which
is neither these but I've kind of like
named this color so I want to put it I
want to place it somewhere so I'm gonna
say for this one here I'm gonna have my
three okay I've got my brown I've got
black and I've got red okay now the
important part that I was trying to get
at is these are mutually exclusive in
one ways you can see is 6 plus 21 plus 1
gives you the 28 gives you the total
does that make sense it exactly lines up
now this is the contrast I want to draw
have a look at this group of people okay
I tell you from the outset just like I
did here
I tell you how many people there are in
the group there are 30 of them and then
I tell you they went shopping and these
were the things that they bought either
milk or bread or neither I want you to
look closely at the numbers this time
what do you notice about them that's
different Jessica
[Music]
ya see your 20 push to 13 push you 1
which gives you what 34 which is more
than the number of customers I'm
supposed to have what does this imply it
means that Louie's so some people must
have got both right because you don't
have enough people to buy just one of
each one you've run out of people so
there have to be some people who did
both and that's how we account for the
numbers so in your book now maybe leave
space for you to complete that question
I'd like you to draw for me a new Venn
diagram I'm drawing it with an overlap
because you told me there have to be
some people who bought Brothe both milk
and bread milk and bread and we're going
to work out how many okay here's my Venn
diagram you can see my universal box on
the outside there's a single person who
bought neither right and I'm gonna start
with them because that's the easiest
number to place on the diagram where
does that one person go on my diagram on
the outside of the circles but inside
the box yeah cuz they're in this group
of 30 that I'm considering okay now stay
with me how many people will be inside
the circles in total now that you know
that ones on the outside they're going
to be 29
very good so I'm not counting down in my
head this is how many people I've got
left to put into the circles okay
now this point seen the number 20 and
the number 13 I can't write them
directly anywhere right because for
example if I wrote 20 here right then
what should be the number that goes here
I think carefully if I've got 20 here
then how many left over people milk to
put in here the answers I don't have any
left right I've accounted for all 20 of
them and we know that can't be the case
you guys told me someone had to buy both
right so I can't do this here's what I'm
going to do instead maybe if you got
like another color or a pencil or
something like that instead I'm going to
draw like a little curly brace down here
this is everyone who's bought milk
there's 20 of them right so if I take
those 20 you
told me I had 29 people left who I could
put inside the circles so why no 20 of
them will be over here so if I take that
29 remove that 20 how many do I have
left I have nine right nine have to be
here does that make sense you following
I took the 29 that had to be inside the
circles I know 20 gonna be over here so
therefore I can infer whoopsie-daisy
there must be 29 take away that 20 over
there don't move we can fill this in now
can't we how many people are left in the
middle I've counted nine I have to add
four to get to 13 and now I can finish
by saying 16 plus 4 gives me the 20 does
that make sense